[Music]
when you are on the point of putting
your hand to some undertaking
remind yourself what the nature of that
undertaking is
if you are going out of the house to
bathe put before your mind what happens
at a public bath
those who splash you with water those
who jostle against you
those who vilify you and rob you and
thus you will set about your undertaking
more securely
if at the outset you say to yourself i
want to take a bath
and at the same time to keep my moral
purpose in harmony with nature
and so do in every undertaking for thus
if anything happens to hinder you in
your bathing you will be ready to say
oh well this was not the only thing that
i wanted but i wanted also to keep my
moral purpose
in harmony with nature and i shall not
so keep it
if i am vexed at what is going on
chapter four is actually one of my
all-time favorite passages
of epictetus and stoic philosophy in
general
in part because it's it's so uh
straightforward and prosaic and yet gets
really to the heart
of everything and and we can apply the
advice that's given here
to practically any activity that we
engage in where we have some sort of
expectations
so he's talking in general and he says
when you were on the points
of putting your hand to some undertaking
some
ergon some some doing some some activity
remind yourself what the nature of that
activity or that undertaking is
what what kind of thing is it is
in in the greek um
don't just tell yourself hey i'm going
to do
x y z say to yourself i'm going to do
x and x usually involves this sort of
thing
and y has these sorts of
things that accompany it and z sometimes
goes
this way and sometimes goes that way
remind yourself about what you're really
getting yourself
in for so you know this is this is
actually advice
that's quite useful because when we have
to to
expect something that we're not entirely
happy about
as an outcome or as
an impediment or as something that that
you know could ruin
or lessen and experience we often want
to like push that aside ah it's not
going to be like that i'm going to go to
the amusement park
and it's going to be so great i'm going
to go on all the roller coasters
and all the rides and my kids are going
to like totally enjoy themselves
and you don't remind yourself of what it
was like last time that you went
where there were all these crowds and it
was hot and
noisy and you know this ride was broken
and you know you you bought some food
but the food wasn't very good
and you know go on and on and on right
so he has a great example here of going
to the baths
he says if you're going out of the house
to bathe now why is he talking about
going
out of the house to bathe well because
you know this is ancient
greek and roman culture where um
you generally some people did take baths
at home
but they also had these great big public
baths
and they were pretty cool places to go
to you know you get to look at other
people
and chat with them and there were
attendants who could like rub you down
with
olive oil and people made a whole
production out of this right
sort of like we make a big production of
going to the gym
or going to the spa so you know you
might substitute something like that
i'm going to go to the spa or i'm going
to go
and have a workout at planet fitness or
at the expensive gym
or whatever you like right i'm going to
go to the y
and lift some weights i can do the same
thing i'm going to get up in front of my
chalkboard and i'm going to give a
lecture you know
i'm going to go and and give a talk here
and there'll be people and they'll ask
these great great questions we'll have
great discussions
so he says okay so you're going to the
bath
what is that actually like
he says put before your mind
what happens at a public bath
don't just say to yourself the words i'm
going to go to the bath
or think to yourself this is going to be
such a great experience
remind yourself about what you actually
know
because you've experienced it or you can
imagine it happening or somebody else
has experienced it and told you about it
so what happens
there's people who splash you with water
right it's like going to a public pool
somebody's going to splash you sometimes
you have a kid who just loves splashing
people right
some people get in and they make a big
splash some people aren't paying
attention to what they're doing
some people will jostle against you
they'll bump into you
some will even vilify you and rob you
they'll say
bad things some will steal your stuff
now you say well i'll make sure that i
you know go in with a lock and
and that way nobody will rob me i don't
know you know
when you go to a health club or you go
to a pool
you know you can put all your stuff in
but even that key that you carry around
i suppose you could use a combination
lock and put everything in there you can
get in the water and somebody can come
along and take your towel
because somebody can take your spot go
to the gym
you know you set yourself your stuff
down for a minute and and it's gone
people talk all sorts of trash about
other people
sometimes you know stupidly sometimes
uh because they they are unhappy with
their own lives sometimes because
they're miserable types of people but
people do that sort of thing
similarly i'll give you you know an
example from my own experience
i've had some lectures where i go and
it's just a
wonderful experience i've had some
lectures where i go
and you know not quite so so so great
you know a few people show up and
somebody starts asking crazy questions
that have nothing to do with the topic
and making assertions
um you know you get people coming up to
you afterwards sometimes saying oh that
was really great
i'd like to get on your mailing list can
i find out about more other people come
up to you and say
you know it was a nice lecture but you
really should have done this
and you didn't talk about this enough
and uh why don't you why did you give us
a handout on that why didn't you give us
a handout on this
instead and people will do this not only
for paid lectures where they were
actually
putting something on the table but for
free lectures
where they could have gone or not gone
and you're doing it entirely
for free for them so there's a lot of
things we could talk about you know is
the chalkboard going to work right
every time you get on your computer
there's the
there's the potential that there's some
sort of catastrophic
failure that's going to happen every
time you get out your phone
every time you go out on a date this
would be a great reminder
for going out on dates what are dates
like you don't actually know the person
that well that's why you're going out on
a date with them
to find out what they're like and
there's lots and lots of ways things can
go bad just between the two people
to make it less of a enjoyable
experience you could go to a restaurant
and somebody gets food poisoning the
server isn't nice the drinks are watered
down
you know you go to see a band the pa
system isn't
done well hasn't been mixed there's all
sorts of things that could be happening
so what can you do now this doesn't mean
that you should just like you know dwell
forever
like a doom and gloom person on
everything that's going to go
bad but it does mean that
you should you know be realistic about
what
what you're getting yourself in for says
you'll go about your undertaking
more securely more securely it will
secure in what sense
secure in that you're not going to lose
it you're not going to
get upset if you say to yourself
i want to take a bath and at the same
time
to keep my moral purpose in harmony with
nature
this is an extremely important phrase
the ideal for epictetus
as for other stoics is to
live in accordance with nature that's
the way it was framed at the beginning
epictetus will talk much more in terms
of
maintaining one's moral purpose or
faculty of choice that is
what what in greek is called the
pro-hyracis
this is the core of the person this is
your your moral compass
this is your capacity to reflexively
choose
what you're going to do how you're going
to feel what you're going to think
it forms your habits it is formed by
your habits it is what
is what allows you to choose it is also
the product of the choices that you make
this is what you are he says
are you going to maintain that in
accordance with nature
or are you going to allow it to get all
out of whack
to be not in accordance with nature to
be discordant with nature
what does he mean by nature he doesn't
mean what we often talk about is natural
oh it's just natural that somebody cuts
you off and you flip them the bird and
yell at them or something like that
that's not natural according to
epictetus
what is natural is what fulfills
our potential as human beings
what is genuinely good for us and for
other people
living in harmony with them as best as
we can to the degree that
you know our idiosyncrasies allow us to
do so
that is being in accordance with nature
fulfilling your duties that you have is
living in accordance with nature
using appearances well as he's going to
talk about in other places
living in accordance with nature so when
you go to the bath
and you know that people are going to do
all these things
you can tell yourself i don't just want
to go to the bath i also
want to maintain my faculty of choice in
accordance with nature
or if we want to talk in more
contemporary parlance
i want to stay on the life track that
i've chosen for myself
i don't want to fall into being upset
into losing my temper into
feeling ashamed or afraid or you know
some having somebody
get me to do something i don't want to
do
that's a that's a major distinction
there
now if you don't think that you can go
to the bath
and deal with everybody's nonsense and
also keep
your your pro-iracious in accordance
with nature
then maybe you shouldn't go to the bath
maybe it's better for you not to do that
if when you go to a concert today
you know it bothers you the fact that
people have like an
ocean of phones and they're all filming
the
people up on stage so it does affect the
light show that you see you can see an
ocean of
little blue lights right and
you find yourself saying what's wrong
with these dummies why can't they enjoy
themselves
if that's going to be what's going to
happen and that's up to you
it doesn't have to happen that way then
maybe you should skip the concert
particularly if you're going to be the
person who gets upset
because you're holding up your own phone
and you don't want all these other
people to have
their phones on the image that you're
taking of the band
there's a whole set of other problems
involved with consistency there but
we can remind ourselves we can we can
you know
be aware we can be mindful
as we move into situations about what
they're likely to entail
we don't have to avoid going to the bath
we don't have to avoid
going to the concert we don't have to
avoid going to the gym
we don't have to avoid getting into our
car we don't have to avoid going to
class
but we should keep our ourselves
attuned to what it is that we're getting
ourselves in for
and not you know give ourselves all
sorts of
idealistic uh imaginary
assurances about how great everything is
going to be
that's counterproductive from a stoic
perspective
it's not engaging with reality
so he says do this with every
undertaking
for thus if anything happens to hinder
you in your bathing
you'll be ready you'll already be
equipped to say
oh well this is not the only thing that
i wanted but i wanted also to keep my
moral purpose in harmony with nature
and i shall not so keep it if i am vexed
at what is going on
so you could go to the concert and you
know you think to yourself ahead of time
all right what happens at concerts
a lot of people jostle each other the
beer is very expensive
it's kind of you know tough getting in
and out because there's so many crowds
uh the the bouncers sometimes like to
you know
prod and probe you a bit uh
but i want to see this band and i want
to see them in their native habitat
up on stage so i'm going to do that
but i also want to maintain my moral
purpose in accordance with nature i also
want to hold it together
i also want to stay on track right
so if things really go well
well you get to have both of them and
you didn't waste your time
thinking ahead of time well what could
go wrong what what
what is likely to happen even though it
didn't happen
because you're still having both things
you're having a great experience
and you're getting to maintain your
progress
now if things go bad you know somebody's
a jerk to you
uh there's usually a lot of ways people
are jerks at concerts right
well you prepared for it and now you can
tell yourself
what i really want is to maintain my
moral purpose in accordance with nature
and if that's what you see is most
valuable
and stoic philosophy does then
you will opt for for that
so this is some really great advice that
can as he says be put into practice
with every single undertaking every
single activity
that we choose to do
it is not the things themselves that
disturb men but their judgments about
these things
for example death is nothing dreadful or
else socrates too would have thought so
but the judgment that death is dreadful
this is the dreadful thing when
therefore we are hindered
or disturbed or grieved let us never
blame
anyone but ourselves that means our own
judgments
it is the part of an uneducated person
to blame others
where he himself fares ill to blame
himself as the part of one whose
education has begun
to blame neither another nor his own
self
is the part of one whose education is
already complete
chapter five is one of the probably most
fruitful and most often commented on
chapters or at least the very first
passage of it is
because it's so central to
stoic practice and stoic approaches to
to things
it's influenced psychotherapy
quite uh quite important so let's take a
look let's jump right in
he says it is not the things themselves
that disturb people but their judgments
about these things people are troubled
thrashing not by
things themselves pragmata the things
states of affairs things that happen to
us
things that go on with our own body
right
but our opinions
our viewpoints our judgments are
in greek dogmata about those
those things so these don't even
necessarily have to be
things that we ourselves have thought up
ourselves
you know through our own activity it
could be
things that we've internalized that
other people have said like
you should always look out for number
one right you hear that often enough
and um you you make that your dogma
it's it's your opinion that you now
bring or your idea that you now bring
to everything and you're placed into a
situation where where you can't just
look out for yourself and you
have to you know take care of somebody
else and now you're upset
right or um winning isn't everything
it's the only thing that's a horrible
thing to say to kids
and actually to adults right
winning is not the only thing
there's a lot of other things as well
but if you've got that
dogma in your head
and you're bringing it to bear what
happens when you lose what happens when
you don't get
when you get second place you're gonna
be quite upset
so how we
think about things the opinions
the ideas the judgments that we bring to
bear
as we take in the world as we move
around in the world
as we experience things
that's what really hurts us that's what
upsets us
it's not the things themselves when we
get angry
it's not just something happening and
impinging on us
it's also what we're contributing to the
situation
what we're bringing in somebody bumps
you right
and you don't know whether or not they
did it on purpose but you're already a
little hot
and tired and you know having to get
somewhere and you turn around and say
what's up with you jerk you've actually
made a decision there
that was not just a reflex action you
brought to bear some idea about what was
going on
you attributed to that person whether
it's true or false that they did that on
purpose
and that the best thing for you is to
call them a jerk
and maybe elbow them back or something
along those lines
there's a lot of cases that we could
talk about so he says
for example
here's a big example right death
death is nothing dreadful why do we know
that death is nothing dreadful
well death is actually something
dreadful for many people isn't
it you say i'm afraid of death
death is not dreadful in itself if it's
dreadful for you
you're contributing something that's
making it so
what's the evidence for that there's a
very simple argument
if death was truly dreadful
everybody would feel dread at death
and he gives one example but we can
think of many other people who don't
socrates socrates who the stoics look at
is kind of a
heroic figure he drank the hemlock
himself
as a matter of fact his jailer told them
hey hey
don't be talking so much you know the
last day of your life with all these
friends of yours
because when you when you drink the
poison it might not work right away
and then i'll have to mix up another
bash and socrates says
this is my last day i'm going to talk if
i want to
mix up another batch because
maybe you'll need it you can count on me
to drink the poison
because i'm going to follow what my city
has decreed in
saying that i must be executed and that
i'm the one who's got to do it
but you handle your business i'll handle
mine i'll do what's up to me that's
right and socrates was not afraid of
death
and it wasn't just because he had this
idea that you know while i'm going to go
to a better place or
or anything like that he you know he
spends his last
uh a few hours in conversation
about the nature of death and the soul
and the body
but he's not bothered by it if he was
bothered by it he would have never gone
to trial in the first place or
after he went to trial he would have
taken credo's uh
preferred opportunity to get get out of
town and go somewhere else and live in
exile
credo bribed the jailers he didn't do
that
so it's not that it's not death itself
that's dreadful
but the judgment that death is dreadful
that is the dreadful thing it's dreadful
in two ways
so it makes death something dreadful
the judgment that death is dreadful
it's also something dreadful or fearful
or something we
should be afraid of to have that very
judgment
because it makes our life life is the
opposite of death
it makes our life something where we
have to have bad experiences about
something we haven't yet
endured or encountered
so our own death is not something that
we
need to fear it is up to us it's our
choice
whether we have that judgment that dogma
or not
that's up to us we get to choose what we
fill our head with
so he goes on and he says
when therefore we are hindered or
disturbed
or grieved when we have negative
experiences
when things don't go our way and then we
react badly
because we're not happy about that as we
euphemistically say we're actually
unhappy about it says let's not blame
anyone but ourselves whose fault is it
that you feel a certain way
it's not somebody else's fault it's your
fault
they may have done some things they may
have acted like a jerk
they may have been thoughtless but it's
your judgments
that contribute to why you feel that way
you're the one who is interpreting what
it is that they're doing
they may act with complete malice but a
stoic
doesn't have to therefore feel
all sorts of negative emotions like
being upset or
you know being terrified of that person
or you know being in a rage against that
person or being
indignant that that person gets away
with what they're doing
that's a choice so he says let us
blame our own judgments
blame ourselves blame our own judgments
so notice what he's
what he's saying there don't blame
yourself like say oh
oh you're such a terrible person there's
nothing good about you whatsoever
look at the part of yourself that is
actually getting yourself
in this trouble if you have a bad temper
because you're constantly judging that
people
are disrespecting you and you're adding
that to perhaps the fact that they are
disrespecting you right
you don't have to condemn your entire
self
you can say well that's not a good part
of me that part of me that has those
judgments
maybe other parts of yourself are very
good hopefully they are
and you can start working on that one
part
it's very important to isolate out
where we're going wrong so he says it's
the part now this is a great
phrase here it's the part of an
uneducated
person to blame others where he himself
fares ill where he
does poorly because of his own screwing
up
so there's lots and lots of people in
the world who think that the world is
screwed up
but they're not screwed up and
the very fact that they think that the
world is so screwed up and it upsets
them
is part of how they're screwed up the
world is what it is
the world works the way the world works
and to expect it or demand that it be
something totally different
that's totally unrealistic
and setting oneself up for all sorts of
moral failures
people don't in general want to take
responsibility
it's the other political party's problem
it's those people over there
it's the the you know the hierarchy the
patriarchy the
you know the liberals the conservatives
the blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
anybody but me stoics are saying no no
it's it's you
pay attention to your own part in it
those other people if if they actually
have some blame
you can blame them all you like after
you looked at your own part
see whether you have some responsibility
actually if you do that you're probably
going to get to the point
where you're not so worried about all of
them
because we do this as a way of
projecting
the the screwed up-ness the
damage that's inside of ourselves onto
everything else so we don't have to face
up to it
as being in us but it should be no
surprise
when we see it recurring over and over
and over again that the problem is in us
so that's the uneducated person the the
person who has not been you know
trained who's not been disciplined then
he says
uh to blame oneself is the part of one
whose education has begun
education in how to live in stoic
philosophy
when you start doing that you'll you
know you'll have the experience it's not
a fun experience
of looking at yourself and saying wow
i'm pretty messed up
there's a lot of things that i've been
telling myself for years where i i'm
i'm well off i'm not so well off when i
face up to things and look at myself
honestly when i let in the antiseptic of
sunlight as we say
into the dark recesses of my my soul
not really happy with what i'm seeing so
they they
blame themselves but that's not the end
of it he says
to blame neither another nor his own
self is the part of one
whose education is already complete the
goal is to get to the point
where you're not criticizing you're not
complaining about you're not finding all
the bad stuff in yourself
and you're not doing it with other
people and the world
you're actually happy you're actually
free
you're actually undisturbed tranquil
so how do these
these all connect with each other how do
we get from the beginning part of
it's not the things themselves that
disturb people but our judgments about
these things
to all this discussion of blame well
when we start actively and honestly
looking at our own psychological makeup
at our own tendencies at our own
judgments about things
that's some of the stuff that we've been
using to blame other people
where really we should be blaming
ourselves criticizing ourselves
not so that we just tear ourselves apart
but so that we can make good changes
that will shift us away from that and
towards something that's more healthy
more
more wholesome something that we can
really get behind
and eventually so we can love ourselves
as we are
you